Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Die größte Fangruppe von Energie Cottbus zieht sich zurück. Grund nach der Scherchen von René Garzke von den Postdamer Neuesten Nachrichten, rechtsextreme Hooligans des eigenen Vereins. Darüber will ich sprechen in Kurzpass Nummer 42. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich ihn persönlich hier in der Leitung begrüßen darf. Hallo René Garzke von den Postdamer Neuesten Nachrichten. Gerne beim Max bleiben. Wir haben uns ja auf das Du schon verständigt vor der Sendung. Ja, lass uns mal an diesem Themenkomplex teilhaben, auf den ich erst vor einiger Zeit aufmerksam wurde. Es gibt eine große Fan-Gruppe von Energie Cottbus. Die heißt Ultima Raka und die hat sich jetzt zurückgezogen. Erklär uns mal so ein bisschen die Hintergründe. Was ist da passiert?
Also man muss da schon ganz grundlegend anfangen. Es ist ja nichts Neues, dass in Ultrakreisen auch im eigenen Verein, dass es dort zu Reibungen kommt, dass es zu dem Ausschluss von einzelnen Gruppen kommt. Also es konnte man zum Beispiel in Braunschweig beobachten, auch in Dresden, dass eher linke Fan-Gruppen von den großen Ultragruppen verdrängt wurden, weil die entweder rechts offen oder sogar rechtsextrem sind und quasi keine linken Gruppen in ihrer Kurve haben wollten. In Cottbus ist es ein bisschen anders. Da gibt es Inferno Cottbus einmal. Die gab es seit 1999. Die haben sich in diesem Jahr aufgelöst, nach Recherchen von uns, den Potsdamer Neuesten Nachrichten und dem RBB. Und diese Recherchen hatten gezeigt, dass Inferno Cottbus versucht, in der eigenen Fanszene andere Fan-Gruppen auch zu unterdrücken, so wie es in den anderen Städten auch war. Anders aber als bei den klassischen Konflikten ist, dass Ultima Raka keine linke Fan-Gruppe ist. Sie ist eher unpolitisch. Und dennoch ist sie zum Zielobjekt von Rechtsextrem Hooligans, das eigene Vereins, geworden.
Wie kann man das belegen? Hat sich der Ultima Raka selbst so geäußert? Wie haben die ihren Rückzug bekannt gegeben?
Also jetzt hat Ultima Raka ihren Rückzug selbst bekannt gegeben über die Webseite. Der Rückzug ist aber nicht als Auflösung der Gruppe zu verstehen, sondern einfach ein Einstellen der Aktivitäten. Sie haben sich vor allem von der Ultra-Bewegung losgesagt. Sie wollen nicht mehr in diesem Machtkampf involviert sein, sondern sie wollen jetzt nur noch als Freunde zum Fußball gehen, aber den ganzen anderen Kram, so Ultra-Kram, die singen und bannermalen und auswärts fahrenden und so eher sein lassen.
Könnte ja auch sein, dass sie einfach nur ein bisschen müde des ewigen Supports sind. Was bringt euch denn dazu, zu glauben, dass da Inferno Cottbus dahintersteckt?
Zum einen ist es die Stellungnahme selbst von Ultima Raka. Die war ein bisschen kryptisch geschrieben. Dort haben sie wörtlich geschrieben, wir sehen nach Gesprächen mit anderen Akteuren über die zukünftige Ausrichtung der Cottbuser Fernszene leider keine Möglichkeit, unser Fandasein weiterhin frei nach unseren Vorstellungen auszulegen. Und wir haben da in der Fernszene nachgefragt. Es will keiner offen reden. Es möchte keiner mit seinem Namen in der Zeitung stehen. Deswegen muss man da auch sehr sensibel mit umgehen. Wir konnten nicht einzelne Gesprächspartner wörtlich zitieren, aber da ist auf jeden Fall rausgekommen, dass es Ende August ein Treffen mit Inferno Cottbus gegeben hat und den ganzen anderen Fangruppen in Cottbus. Bei diesem Treffen wollte Inferno eine Art Dachverband einführen, also einen großen Zusammenschluss aller verschiedenen Gruppen. Und quasi die Fernszene so einen, Ultima Raka wollte das aber nicht. Die Gründe haben sie nicht bekannt gegeben. Nach unseren Recherchen war es zum einen der Gedanke, dass Inferno Cottbus so die Möglichkeit hätte, eine große Bühne zu bekommen, auch für rechtsextreme Propagande. Also es gab zahlreiche Vorfälle in der Vergangenheit, wo sowas schon vorkam. Zum Beispiel hat Inferno Cottbus mal eine Choreo gemacht. Dort haben sie den Spruch mit einzelnen Buchstaben hochgehalten, ein Sieg heilt alle Wunden. Und kurz danach sind einzelne Buchstaben runtergegangen, sodass nur noch die Buchstaben Sieg heilt.
Komischer Zugang.
Und die Sicherheitsbehörden beobachten Inferno Cottbus natürlich auch intensiv. Zum ersten Mal ist in diesem Jahr Inferno Cottbus und die Nachwuchstruppe Unbequeme Jugend, also die Jugendorganisation von Inferno, die sind zum ersten Mal in diesem Jahr auf dem Verfassungsschutzbericht als rechtsextreme Strukturen aufgeführt.
Und haben sich ja aber, also Inferno Cottbus jetzt laut eigener Aussage aufgelöst, wo aber auch schon der Innenminister Brandenburgs Karl-Heinz Schröter gesagt hat, von der SPD, naja, ob das jetzt wirklich eine Auflösung war, nur weil die das von sich behaupten, man kann sich ja auch unter neuer Fahne wieder treffen oder verdeckt agieren. Wie ist das einzuschätzen?
Also Inferno Cottbus hat sich Ende, nee, im Mai hat Inferno Cottbus sich aufgelöst, nach Recherchen von RBB und PNN. Und klar, alle, alle die Szene beobachten und auch die in der Szene drin sind, haben nicht so richtig an diese Auflösung geglaubt. Also die war wahrscheinlich eher um einem Vereinsverbot zuvor zu kommen, weil die Artikel, die wir geschrieben haben, auch durchaus den Schluss zugelassen haben, dass es sich dort um eine kriminelle Struktur handelt. Also wir haben wörtlich auch von einem kriminellen Netzwerk geschrieben, weil es von Inferno auch Verbindungen in die örtliche Rocker- und in die Türschwer-Szene gibt und auch in dieses Milieu, also Drogenhandel spielt auch eine Rolle. Und durch diese fortlaufenden Einschüchterungen in der Fanszene ist da durchaus die Frage angebracht, ob es sich nicht um eine kriminelle Vereinigung handelt und die deswegen verboten werden könnte. Und dem wollte Inferno halt zuvorkommen. Wie jetzt aber die Auflösung von, oder die das Einstellen der Aktivitäten von Ultima Raka gezeigt hat, ist Inferno weiter aktiv. Im Hintergrund, sie hängen nicht mehr ihr Banner auf, das dürfen sie je nicht, weil sie mit einem Erscheinungsverbot belegt sind im Cottbuser Stadion.
Da hätte ihnen natürlich der neue Dachverband auch ganz gut geholfen.
Genau, der hätte denen da sehr, sehr gut geholfen. Zum einen hätten sie dann wieder ein Emblem und könnten Banner aufhängen und es würde nicht so leicht als Nachfolgestruktur wieder mit einem Erscheinungsverbot zu belegen sein, weil die Struktur nicht mehr deckungsgleich ist zu der vorherigen, wo nur Inferno Cottbus war. Also, ich hoffe, das war verständlich.
Und seit wann kann man denn Inferno Cottbus als das, was es ist, eine kriminelle Struktur, nach allem, was man über die weiß, seit wann kann man das festmachen? Also, du hast vorhin mal kurz erwähnt, 99 gegründet. War das schon immer so? Hat sich das entwickelt?
Also, in Cottbus gab es zum Beispiel schon 1997 ein Vorfall, dass Gerald Asamoah mit Bananen beworfen wurde und mit Affenlauten empfangen wurde. Da gab es Inferno Cottbus noch nicht. Aber es gab immer wieder Vorfälle aus dem Inferno-Umfeld, aus dieser Struktur. 2005 zum Beispiel. Das ist ganz bekannt. Hatten die Cottbuser einen Dresden-Banner hochgezogen mit Juden drauf. Und das D war dieses Dynamo-D. Das ist ganz bekannt, immer wenn es um Antisemitismus in den Stadien geht.
Das ist das Symbolfoto, oder?
Genau, das ist das Symbolfoto. Und es kam immer wieder zu Vorfällen. Auch 2012 wurde hier ein Neonazienetzwerk in Brandenburg verboten. Das hat sich mit so nächtlichen Fackelaufmärschen aufmerksam gemacht. Das war die Widerstandsbewegung Süd-Brandenburg. Und auch dort hatte Inferno Cottbus personelle Verbindungen. Also es gab Überschneidungen. Auch in der örtlichen Neonaziestruktur ist Inferno Cottbus immer aufgefallen. Anfang des Jahres war das Revival. Das hat das Ganze noch mal in den Fokus gerückt. Im Januar sind 120 Neonazis nachts durch Cottbus gezogen, mit Fackeln unangemeldet. Und die Polizei konnte nichts ausrichten, weil sie nichts zuvor mitbekommen hat. Und zu spät kam das Wort. Das war so ein bisschen das Revival.
Das heißt, das kann ja auch dem Verein nicht entgangen sein. Also wir können jetzt nicht davon sprechen, wir haben ja gar nicht gewusst, was das für Leute sind, welches politische oder von Politik will ich da gar nicht mehr sprechen, Gedankengut, die verfolgen. Das ist für jeden, der sich ein bisschen mit Energie Cottbus beschäftigt, offenkundig.
Ja, genau, das ist für jeden offenkundig. Also solche Choreos wie diese Sieg Heil Buchstaben, die können im Stadion einem nicht entgehen. Und gerade auch das Judenbanner, so oft wie das in den Medien ist, das kann keinem entgehen. Und ganz krass war dieses Jahr in Potsdam hier bei uns, war Ende April Energie Cottbus zum Auswärtsspiel hier. Und dort gab es dann Gesänge wie Arbeit macht frei, Babelsberg 03, Hitlergrüße, Platzsturm, also das volle Programm. Und genau, und danach kam dann auch zum Vorschein diese kriminelle Struktur und die Einschüchterung in der Fernzene. Allerdings kam die nur durch Recherchung der Medien zum Vorschein.
Was mich schon zu der Frage brächte, was tut eigentlich der Verein, also um das nochmal einzuordnen, wir sprechen hier bei der Ultima Raka von der größten Fan-Gruppe von Energie Cottbus. Und die stellen ihre Aktivitäten ein und das liegt ja wirklich sehr nahe zu glauben. Da gibt es einen Zusammenhang mit rechtsextremen Kriminellen wahrscheinlich sogar. Was macht der Verein?
Bei dem Verein ist es ein bisschen schwierig. Da hat auch unser Innenminister, Karl-Heinz Schroeter, sehr deftige Worte gefunden, um das zu beschreiben. Er hat gesagt, es gab immer wieder Spräche zwischen den Sicherheitsbehörden und dem Verein. Um eben dieses Problems herzuwerden. Der Innenminister hat dann gesagt, wenn der Verein das nicht umsetzt, muss man sich auch nicht wundern, wenn aus einem kleinen Krebsgeschwür eine große Wuchruhung entsteht. Das war immer so, dass Energie Cottbus das Erscheinungsverbot 2013 hatte, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, genau 2013 für Inferno ausgesprochen.
Was ja schon unglaublich spät ist, ehrlich gesagt. Also das ist nach so einem Juden-Banner noch, das war doch 2005, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung gehabt habe. Da sind ja acht, das ist ja unfassbar.
Das stimmt, aber dennoch, also war quasi dieses Signal 2013 dann das Erscheinungsverbot. Fälschlicherweise wurde es von vielen Medien als Stadionverbot beschrieben, aber der Unterschied ist eben bei einem Erscheinungsverbot, dürfen die Leute weiter ins Stadion. Sie dürfen nur nicht ihre Symbole zeigen, keine Banner mehr zeigen und sich als Gruppe quasi nicht zu erkennen geben. Und das heißt, weil es nur ein Erscheinungsverbot war, waren die Leute weiter im Stadion und es kam weiter zu Vorfällen.
Ja super toll. Warum gab es denn da keinen Stadionverbot? Ich denke damals wurde die Frage doch sicher häufiger gestellt.
Das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht rekapitulieren, da will ich nichts Falsches sagen. Fakt ist auf jeden Fall, dass seit dem letzten Sommer, Sommer 2016, ein neuer Präsident bei Energie ist, Michael Warlich. Und der hat auch selbst seine Vorgänger kritisiert. Er hat gesagt, wenn man eine Weile wegguckt, wenn nichts passiert, hat die andere Seite Gelegenheit, sich neu zu formieren und zu strukturieren. Und er geht jetzt ein bisschen entschlossener dagegen vor, immer wenn es zu Vorfängen kommt von Inferno Cottbus, gibt es eine entschiedene Pressemitteilung des Vereins. Es soll eine Stelle für Toleranz und Vielfalt eingerichtet werden beim Verein. Und der Verein hat jetzt Kontakt aufgenommen zu dem Bündnis Cottbuser Aufbruch. Das ist so eine zivilgesellschaftliche Vereinigung in Cottbus, die sich gegen Rechtsextremismus einsetzt und halt auch stetisch gefördert wird.
Das heißt, mit etwas Verspätung kann man, also mit deutlicher Verspätung, nicht etwas Verspätung. Wir sprechen hier nicht mehr in deutsche Bahndimensionen, sondern noch, also wir sprechen in Berliner Flughafendimensionen. Ja, okay, also ist er etwas aktiver geworden. Glaubst du denn, dass das auch etwas hilft? Denn ehrlich gesagt wirkt das nach außen hin. Mir war der Themenkomplex in der Detailtiefe noch nicht bekannt. Das wirkt wie eine für die nahe Zukunft erstmal aussichtslose Situation. Denn was will man denn machen, wenn ich mir auch durchlese, was die Nachwuchsgruppe Unbequeme Jugend, die machen ihrem Namen mehr als nur alle Ehre. Was kann man denn da überhaupt machen als Verein und auch als Fanszene?
Also ganz offenkundig zeigt ja die Auflösung von Ultima Raka, dass das Problem immer noch nicht gelöst ist, auch wenn der Verein versucht, dem Entschiedener entgegenzutreten. Ja, es ist schwierig. Also zum einen ist sicherlich Strafverfolgung eine gute Methode. Allerdings klagt auch die Polizei, dass sie keine Zeugenaussagen bekommt. Und das hat nämlich, also wenn es einen Vorfall gab, also es gibt, Inferno bedroht die anderen Fan-Gruppen auch außerhalb des Stadels. Also es zeigt sich nicht nur im Stadeln, sondern auch viel, viel mehr außerhalb des Stadels, dass Leute bedroht werden, dass Leute auch zu Hause aufgesucht werden. Und wenn solche Vorfälle passieren, braucht die Polizei natürlich Zeugenaussagen. Und die gibt es aber nicht, weil die bedrohten Fans sich vor weiteren Bedrohungen oder auch Übergriffen fürchten und deswegen nicht ihren Namen in irgendeiner Ermittlungsakte stehen haben wollen. Weil auch wenn sie jemanden anzeigen, also sagen wir sie zeigen Person A an, dann wird eben Person B das nächste Mal die Bedrohung übernehmen, sodass man dem schlecht her werden kann. Ich glaube, da bräuchte es irgendwie ein Zugehen auf die Fans, dass irgendwie ermöglicht wird, dass solche Strafanzeigen möglichst anonym passieren, vielleicht auch im Zeugenschutzprogramm. Und zum anderen hat auch schon Fanforscher Robert Klaus gesagt, dass die Gerichte besser ausgestattet werden müssen. Dass, wenn es Anzeigen gibt, diese Strafanzeigen auch schnell in Gerichtsverfahren münden und schnelle Urteile gesprochen werden. Ja, und ansonsten ist der Verein jetzt erstmal, glaube ich, auf einem ganz guten Weg, dass er das Problem offensiv benennt, auch angeht. Und es bräuchte aber aus meiner Sicht auch in der ganzen Stadt eine Ächtung dieser rechtsextremen Klientel. Also die muss ich nicht nur im Stadion zeigen, sondern auch in der Stadt.
Wie ist da die Situation in Cottbus?
Also Cottbus ist definitiv in Brandenburg der Hotspot der rechten Szene. Das zeigt sich auch an Anti-Asyl-Demonstrationen, die es seit mehr als einem Jahr mindestens gibt, wo mehrere hundert Leute mitlaufen. Es gibt jetzt auch die Identitäre Bewegung dort. Und es gibt eben solche Neonazi-Netzwerke, die sich dann zeigen wie im Januar bei dem Fackelmarsch, wo 120 Leute auf einmal nachts durch die Straße marschen.
Also ihr habt mal in einem Artikel geschrieben, fast jede fünfte der 2016 in Brandenburg verübten 167 rechten Gewalttaten registrierte der Verfassungsschutz in Cottbus. Das, glaube ich, macht die Dimension klar, wenn du sagst Hotspot der rechten Szene.
Genau, das ist zur Einordnung sicherlich gut, Jan. Ja, also da ist es definitiv ein großes Problem. Man wird eben, wie gesagt, nicht nur mit Sprachverfolgung entgegnen können, aber es ist sicherlich auch ein Teil davon und es braucht einfach eine Ächtung, auch in der Fanszene. Zum Beispiel hat eine andere große Gruppe in Cottbus auf diese Stellungnahme von Ultima Raka reagiert und auch auf unsere Medienberichte, wonach das mit Inferno Cottbus zu tun hätte und die versucht, das so ein bisschen runterzuspielen. Also die Gruppe heißt Kollektivo Bianco Rosso, hat nach Angaben der Sicherheitsbehörden etwa 50 Mitglieder und die haben quasi versucht, diese politische Dimension rauszunehmen.
Das berühmte Fußball ist unpolitisch Argument.
Genau, richtig. Und ich glaube, sowas ist gerade nicht förderlich, wenn man dem Problem beikommen möchte. Sondern es muss vor allem auch Solidaritätsbegründung mit Ultima Raka geben. Das hatte das Fanprojekt zuvor schon eingefordert vom Verein. Offenbar hat das alles nichts genützt.
Das heißt, bei allem kleinen Fortschritten, die wir dem Verein attestieren können, liegt aber auch noch einiges im Argen. Ehrlich gesagt tröstet mich auch eine Stelle für Toleranz und Vielfalt beim Verein herzlich wenig.
Ja, also es ist sicherlich erst mal ein symbolischer Akt. Man muss schauen, wie diese Stelle dann konkret ausgestaltet wird.
Ja, aber die Zeit der Symbolik müsste doch eigentlich jetzt vorbei sein. Also man hatte dieses Problem schon seit Jahren und hat es damals noch klein geredet, ignoriert, hat weggeguckt und deutlicher kann es jetzt nicht mehr werden. Also was soll die nächste Eskalationsstufe sein? Sehen wir dann Hakenkreuze irgendwann im Stadion und dann reiben wir uns vor Wunder die Augen und sagen uns, ach, wo kommt denn jetzt auf einmal die Nazis her? Eigentlich müsste doch jetzt der Verein mit allem, was in seiner Kraft steht, sich dagegen wehren und zwar auf allen Ebenen. Also nicht nur zu sagen, wir machen Fanprojekte, sondern auch zum Beispiel als Verein für all das stehen, was Nazis hassen. Vielfalt, Offenheit, Toleranz, gerne auch freie Liebe für alle. Wenn der Verein dafür ganz deutlich eintreten würde in allem, was er tut, dann zeigt er ja ganz eindeutig, wir stehen für etwas komplett anderes als ihr.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Hebel wirklich funktioniert. Also der funktioniert sicher in der Außenwahrnehmung des Vereins und seiner Fernszene. Aber es gab schon beim Auswärtsspiel in Bautzen im März dieses Jahres, hatte Inferno Cottbus und die Unbequeme Jugend, hatten Pyrotechnik gezündet. Obwohl die anderen Fankruppen das verhindern wollten, weil der Verein sowieso schon in einer schlechten Situation war und die wollten das verhindern, haben versucht auf die einzuwirken. Die haben trotzdem die Pyrotechnik gezündet, haben auch Ordner mit Böllern, mit Knallkörpern beworfen und so ganz bewusst dem Verein auch geschadet. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass dieser Hebel nicht zwingend funktioniert, weil die Leute wären trotzdem noch da und würden dann einfach bewusst dem Verein sparen. Interessant damals im Bau zu sein war, weil bei der Pyrotechnik wird ja eine große Blockfahne gehisst, unter der sich dann diejenigen, die die Pyrotechnik zünden, vermummend andere Kleidung anziehen, damit sie schwerer zu identifizieren sind. Und die wird dann auch nach einer Pyrotechnik wieder gehisst, damit die Vermummung abgelegt werden kann und sich wieder die andere Kleidung angezogen werden kann. Und diese Block-Fahne hatten die anderen Fans im Gästeblock in Bautzen heruntergezogen nach der Pyro-Aktion, sodass diejenigen quasi offengelegt wurden, die die Pyrotechnik zu verantworten hatten. Und das hat Inferno als Verrat gewertet. Viel, viel schlimmer war ja noch, dass der Verrat aus der eigenen Fanszene kam. Und ja, das hat quasi den Stein ins Rollen gebracht, wenn man so will.
Hat es denn dann auch geholfen, dass es da Stadionverbote gab? Denn ich würde, das ist schon so eine Frage, die mir immer wieder latent auf der Zunge lag, jetzt schon in der ganzen letzten 25 Minuten, halben Stunde. Erscheinungsverbot, ja, schön und gut, aber die haben sich ja auch durchaus nicht zu knapp auch Sachen geleistet, für die du gut und gerne ein Stadionverbot bekommst. Und meine Güte, das bekommst du heutzutage dafür, wenn du dein Eis auf eine falsche Art und Weise im betrunkenen Zustand isst.
Also Stand Ende Juli gab es bei Energie Cottbus 47 Stadionverbote. Das hat das Innenministerium in einer Antwort auf eine parlamentarische Anfrage bekannt gegeben. Allerdings ist nicht bekannt, auf welche Gruppen diese Stadionverbote, zu welchen Teilen entfallen. Deswegen ist es für mich zurzeit auch nicht nachprüfbar, ob es nach diesem Vorfall in Bautz eine Stadionverbote gab. Wo der Verein Stadionverbote auf jeden Fall angekündigt hat, war nach dem Auswärtsspielen Wabelsberg und dem Hitlergrüßen und Platzschurm. Da hat er sogar mit lebenslangen Stadionverboten gedroht. Ob es dazu schon kam, ob sie schon ausgesprochen wurden, ist bislang auch nicht bekannt. Wir hatten im Mai dazu angefragt. Da gab es keine Antwort vom Verein.
Was ja auch nicht wirklich hilfreich ist, oder? Also wenn wir über die Rolle des Vereins in dem ganzen Konglomerat sprechen, dann wäre eine transparentere Kommunikationspolitik doch auch ein Baustein.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich muss sagen, ich bin da auch anders dran als vielleicht die Kollegen und der Lausitzer Rundschau, die direkt vor Ort sind und den Sporteil dort machen. Ich betrachte das quasi eher aus einer innenpolitischen Perspektive. Und es kann sein, dass mir da auch mal eine Pressemitteilung des Vereins durchrutscht. Prinzipiell arbeitet der Verein aber aus meiner Sicht schon relativ transparent in seinen Pressemitteilungen.
Was würdest du denn jetzt als Beobachter der Szene und auch etwas weiter entfernt sitzender Beobachter? Welche Perspektive würdest du für Energie Cottbus zeichnen? Das sieht nach einer sehr, sehr schlimmen Situation aus, die auch nicht ganz neu ist. Du hast es vorhin auch schon erwähnt. Das haben wir auch schon bei anderen Vereinen erlebt. Das ist jetzt nur der jüngste Vorfall und auch ein plakativer Vorfall, weil es die größte Fan-Gruppe betrifft, die sich zurückzieht unter den Druck von Nazis. Welche Perspektive ziehst du da für Verein, Umfeld und Fanszene?
Also die Perspektive sieht erst mal düster aus, gerade nachdem Ultima Raka seine Aktivitäten eingestellt hat. Solange es da nicht irgendwie einen großen Ruck gibt in der Fanszene und Solidaritätsbekundung mit Ultima Raka, glaube ich, dass da nicht viel zu holen ist, um Inferno einzudämmen. Und gerade, wenn es Gruppen gibt, die mitmachen wollen in diesem Dachverband, dann sehe ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen Schwarz drauf. Es gibt noch das Fanprojekt durchaus, aber da fehlen, das ist ja auch eine offene Jugendarbeit. Das heißt, die Leute müssen dorthin kommen. Sie müssen Interesse haben. Und ich glaube, bei einem großen Teil der Fans ist dieses Interesse nicht vorhanden.
Ja klar, ich meine, wenn Cottbus generell als Stadt, als Region schon Zulaufstelle ist, Anlaufstelle für viele Rechtsextreme, dann wirkt sich das natürlich auch im Fußball aus. Und der Fußball wird das genauso wenig alleine lösen können, wie es quasi die Region für sich lösen kann. Aber das ist ja weniger ein Grund, den Kopf in den Sand zu stecken, als vielmehr noch lauter dagegen einzutreten.
Genau. Also man muss auch sagen, natürlich sind bei Energie Cottbus nicht alle Fans Neonazis. So ist das ja in den seltensten Fällen. Sondern es gibt halt einen kleinen Teil, der ja sehr machtvoll ist, der halt eben auch gewaltbereit bzw. gewaltsuchend ist. Und es braucht einfach Leute, die das Bild von Energie Cottbus anders prägen als diese Gruppen Inferno Cottbus und Unbequeme Jugend. Und da hilft es nicht, die Probleme klein zu reden, sondern man muss sie offensiv benennen. Und auch die normalen Fans, die nicht in der Ultra-Bewegung irgendwie in Erscheinung treten, von denen könnten auch Abgrenzungen stärker zu erwarten sein.
Letzte Frage. Glaubst du eine größere bundesweite Berichterstattung? Denn meiner Meinung nach war das Thema jetzt nicht allzu groß in den überregionalen Medien. Zumindest wäre es dann an mir vorbeigegangen. Wäre das hilfreich in einer solchen Situation? Oder hätten wir da eher den Effekt, dass wir die Rechtsextremen auf eine Plattform heben, die sie eigentlich gar nicht verdient haben?
Na ja, es ist so ein bisschen tricky, die ganze Sache, weil die Informationen, die wir zutage fördern, sind halt aus Recherchen. Und diesen Zugang zu finden in die Fernsehne, ich weiß nicht, ob der jedem Medium gelingt, aber prinzipiell gab es zumindest, im Mai gab es schon eine größere Berichterstattung. Es hängt auch damit zusammen, dass wir als Potsdamer Neuesten Nachrichten zum Tagesspiegel gehören und das dort auch auf eine größere Plattform heben können. Man beobachtet ja bei Borussia Dortmund zum Beispiel, dass da die Rechtsextremen-Fans bundesweit in den Medien stattfinden. Und so wie ich es beobachten konnte, auch im Stadion in Dortmund, gibt es dadurch beim Verein auch eine sehr, sehr hohe Sensibilität für das Thema. Es gibt zum Beispiel an den Bierständen Flyer mit rechtsextremen Symboliken, also dort werden die erklärt für den normalen Stadion-Zuschauer, so dass er das einordnen kann. Und das findet quasi Bildungsarbeit während des normalen Fußballspiels statt. Und das finde ich schon sehr glücklich mit dem Weg, den Borussia Dortmund dort geht.
Dann werden wir beobachten, wie das bei Energie Cottbus und auch noch allen anderen Vereinen so weitergeht. René, ich denke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du uns Einblick gegeben hast in diese Fanszene, die ja nicht für jeden ein offenes Buch ist, so wie für dich. Sehr gerne. Man kann dir folgen auf Twitter. Dort heißt du EdRenéGarzke. Ich werde dich natürlich in den Show Notes verlinken. Und danke dir sehr herzlich fürs Mitmachen. Und allen Hörern und Hörerinnen danke ich sehr herzlich fürs Zuhören. Tretet ein gegen rechtsextremes Gedankengut, wo immer ihr könnt, so laut ihr könnt. Dem dürfen wir nicht viel Platz geben. Zumindest keinen unwidersprochenen Platz. In diesem Sinne, herzlichen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und wir hören uns in einer der nächsten Folgen des Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, eine gute Zeit. Macht's gut, ciao.